Tom Brady's jersey was stolen from his
bag after winning Super Bowl 51 but the
story of how he got it back is worth
listening to if you recall Brady led the
biggest comeback in Super Bowl history
but just like the Falcons blown 283 lead
the legendary Jersey had gotten lost
quickly in all the commotion or so we
thought but with the help of the FBI and
a 19-year-old Sports collector named
Dylan they were able to track down
Martin Orga who was behind all of this
Orga tried to flip the game War Jersey
to Dylan but his plans got sacked the
FBI Tracked Down the jersey in Mexico
and even proved it was Ortega through
security footage that night but the
other items they found with Ortega were
even more disturbing to see he had not
one but two of Brady's game wor jerseys
one from Super Bowl 51 and 49 he even
had a Denver Broncos helmet that
belonged to Von Miller after winning
Super Bowl 50 Brady will I'm not the
press charges against him but if you're
a player you ever happen to win a Super
Bowl make sure you have everything
locked up tight